ثلاثه ايام مدفونه في قبر وهي على قيد
الحياه سيده وقعت ضحيه لزوجها بحسب
روايتها استخرج لها شهاده وفاه واصدر
تصريح دفن والسبب الطمع في الميراث
تعرفت على جوزك منين
مريض اللي هي كانت اخته وانا كنت في
امتياز مستشفى الجامعه طيب وهو قبل
الواقعه دي يعني خلال جوازكم كان بيعاملك
طول الوقت بطريقه
وحشه ولا كان بيعاملك في الاول كويس لحد
خلاف معين هو من قبلها كنت متخانقين جامد
لان هو كان عايز يصفرني بره تاني واسيب
الاربع اولاد فقلت له انا مستحيل هسيب
الاربع اولاد واسافر تاني لان هم يعني
كلهم اتبهدلوا كتير بيطلب منك تسافري بره
ليه
بحكم وظيفه فاطلع بره اشتغل وابعت له هو
الفلوس وكان الابتزاز كان بيبتزني ببنتي
يعني ايه بيبتزك بعيالك
مش هتشوفي اخد بنت كتير مش هتشوفيها تاني
خالص لان هتسافري وتشتغلي يوم الواقع انا
كنت راجعه من الشغل جاب لي كوبايه عصير
وانا بشرب عصير انا ما حسيتش باي حاجه
يعني لما فوقت لقيت نفسي في مكان ضلمه
خالص وكل ما ارفع راسي انا برده ما فيش
احساس بالوعي خالص افقد الوعي تاني قعدت
افكر يعني معقول انا دفنوني طب انا مت وهم
او في غيبوبه ويفتكروني ان انا اموت او
كده
وافقت الواحد نهائي خالص كنت بحس باصوات
جزم بس مش فاهمه في ايه لغايه
كثير كثير كثير كل ما حسيت بحركات حواليا
من فوق قعدت اصوت اصوت لغايه ما اجي
لقيت ثلاث اشخاص بيفتحوا بيفتح المدفن
ركبنا عربيه وراح ودينا لغايه الباب اللي
احنا منعرفنيش ولا انت تعرفينه
دخلت كان في الدور الثاني يا دوبك طلعت
بخبط على الباب راح هو واخوه فتحه وانت لا
وانت ما بتموتيش لقيت اخوه بيجري بيخبطني
على دماغي وبعدين رحت فوقت لقيت نفسي في
اوضه الاوضه دي عامله زي الباترون بالظبط
كانك باترون وفران وصراصير وبقيت نفسي
مربوطه من ورا مربوطه من تحت
شعرك محلوق خالص داخل عليا بسلك الكهرباء
فيشه وسكينه كهربا وبيحط الفيشه وبيكهرب
فيا
وقال لي مش انت عصطيني وقلت ان انا مش مش
هسافر ولا هروح اجيب فلوس تاني ولا هعمل
حاجه تاني انا هورث وانت عايش انت كده كده
متي وطرب وخبط وعلى طول حتى لما كان بياثر
الضرب بينزل دم يعني يجيب توم توم ويتعب
بالجرح عشان ما تناميش قعدت فتره كبيره
ما كنتش عارفه جبتيه الزمن فكرت الاحساس
بالزمن نهائي بنتي راحت اتصلت بالشرطه كان
سايب الموبايل
لما رحنا الشرطه كنت في حاله عيال شديده
في النيابه قعدت تقريبا قعدنا يومين ثلاثه
بيتحقق معانا اكتشفت اربع سنين محبوسه على
كده انت قدام الحكومه وفي كل الدنيا ان
انا ميته انا بنتي مش عارفه اطلعها شهاده
اللي هي البطاقه ايه رد فعل اهلك لما كنت
بحاول الغي لاي حد انا كده كده اهلي علاقه
معايا لان انا متجوزه في عدم يعني هم ما
كانوش واقفين عليه نهائي فضلتي مدفونه كم
يوم الحكومه قالت يوم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات